yeah Alex Alex hey you okay Alex okay
you're okay hey you're getting your arm
you're okay don't worry they're my
people now be more open to sharing their
vulnerabilities with you and what I said
was hey you got inspired by Alex's story
you need to tell him because alex is one
words belong he made you feel belong
enough that you wanted to come up and
tell me this huge secret of yours so you
have to tell him because we're gonna
make him teary-eyed now because even if
all of these Punk's you know don't like
it like do it for Alex because the
message was so valuable to you that you
were willing to share it like you owe it
to him to say what that means to you so
Alex didn't know we were doing this he
thought he was going to teach more
bachata so we got to do this instead
[Music]
[Applause]
Marc is something
and I think that's my biggest strength
and to be honest I think which has a
special announcement
[Applause]
it's a two-time this is this is the
memory will be 70 rolling on our
wheelchairs create and belong oh my gosh
oh let's do it let's do it here we go
yeah yeah appreciate this is a really
big deal actually yeah my name is Mikael
I've been an artist for pretty much all
my life I was drawing painting and
around four years ago I decided to make
this transition to go into tattoos so
I've been doing tattoos for almost four
years right now and I worked it into
people tattoos and I love my job and
this is this is was one bathroom that I
made in my life and today we're gonna be
tattooing Alex and time panicking
panicking in a good way in a good way
it's a good thing that's really
that's the first one but I think this
one is gonna go better in your hand this
is one yeah
is the tea needs to look appropriate to
the size of your arm okay thinking about
this right here because I don't know I
always like signature you know so maybe
I like the way this he is and I like the
way that a is so I can only imagine what
the sea is going to look like or create
yeah you like that I want to say I was
born ready but I was not born
I have not bored I was not born ready
for this but I made
ready how much is he gonna hurt I'll
scale one to ten ten being is about
getting a blood test
no it's always okay so getting the blood
test late
I almost good huh I don't look bad right
but bad no not bad not bad nobody knew
about yeah yeah I kind of feel like a
badass right now be honest recording
myself getting into yeah I would never
have imagined even two three years ago
that would be doing this a year ago that
would be doing this changes yeah well
yeah but when I did the process to
figure out what my core value is that's
my core value for three months I was
arguing with Evan that I'm like you
can't reduce yourself to one word you
can't like people are too complex and
now I'm getting a tattoo with my one
word so now I just you know you know
nothing right I am admitting gratitude
and growth and that there's so much more
for me to learn
oh my god okay hey take a look I'm
excited this is amazing Wow
[Music]
you know I gotta say I'm grateful that
Evan helped me get over my stubbornness
not about the tattoo but my one word I'm
scared
especially since he's not numbing it I
mean you don't have to film it and I
need you to like fully focus on yeah and
I don't want to jerk a move because this
has always been my issue and I go to
like get my physicals okay all right
sorry that's weird I don't remember
let's go
oh you're fine you're fine your father
Alex
if I'm moving too much please tell me
who's the first person you want to see
this is not for anybody but me okay so I
used to have an earring mm-hmm please
have an earring and I got rid of it one
of my exes didn't like it so I got rid
of it and then when I became single than
I was think about getting the earring I
was talking to Evan and I was like I
want to get the earring back and he's
like but why do you want to get it he's
like I don't know because I think it
would look cool and he's like that is
the worst reason to get anything like
coolness for yourself sure woman when I
said cool it was like I'll get
validation or so definitely this wasn't
because of coolness but that's good
awareness I think that whenever you do
anything should be an expression for
yourself and the Y is more important
always than the execution yeah Alex Alex
hey you okay Alex
okay you okay hey yo get your arm you're
okay don't worry don't worry the next
about oh wait we might worried about
there you go see is is all in your mind
[Music]
we're done
Wow really oh it's done are you serious
put a maple leaf on there I'm just
kidding I love it I freaking love it
thank you so much for opening thank you
so much this is life-changing and I'm
not doing this because of people
watching or whatever like dudes like
this is life-changing this is forever
gonna remind me to never stop just keep
creating no matter who tells me I can't
do it
you're like look who you talkin to this
is Tam cam I create you dude
right at the mirror it's always good to
see okay why are we so nervous oh my oh
because I'm black okay take two why was
I so nervous I mean like really I mean
yeah this was like thank you guys for
helping me choose this and thank you mr.
artist I do hope you realize like it's
thanks to you that this
yeah for me yeah yeah see that's what I
needed and then I mean us like what
business - you need someone to hold you
accountable you know I mean I don't have
a business partner but I need people who
are in my tribe to like say you can do
it because it's hard you know this is
hard you know I miss Tucker week as we
all seem to be we need that butch you
know huh y'all need yeah I mean I've
created my whole life you know
when my family you know didn't support
me and some things you know I created
our own family you know my friends
became my family you know oh my gosh can
I say something I'm the same way so wait
I defined families they're different so
like I love my mom I love my brother
amens I love my dad all that but the
world is my family right schools my
family exactly it's weird
so whenever people you know even
whenever they're dating someone says oh
what I love spending time with my family
I mean I can eat too but I'm like I need
to explain because right like I want to
see my mom or my brother for like a
month or two and that's okay for max to
love them it doesn't but like I totally
get it oh my gosh Wow okay all they say
you know those who are who support you
to Mo's are more there for you to most
our family like people who support um
you know that's family exactly I know
I'm supposed to like be down with okay
yet it blow it I'll do whatever but I
feel like if you don't I mean you can
love somebody but I feel like if you'd
like somebody that's either strong and
in love even though you don't seem like
it
but I mean in my eyes if you really
genuinely like somebody you know
then the love comment will you always I
just because I remember I was younger
and and then you know sometimes like one
of my families you do something bad I
would get matter that I don't want off
this person and my mom would be like
their blood and I'm like I don't care
right like you treat me like a human
being you treat others that need to work
or I write you off yeah
listen what well that's gotten I gotten
better at not holding grudges yes what
I've learned in to hurt you more than it
hurt them yeah it's like it's like
trying to poison someone else but you're
the poison right so what I've learned
you know during the workshops is you
know just to let it go I can make a
decision and let it go don't be like oh
I wish I wish I wish because that's
still harbour scene like you know I wish
this could be you know so I'm fine with
not having the support of my family you
know in in my venture in life you know I
mean it's what makes me happy like I
love being here like I'm like I'm alone
I mean I came into this country and I
know I'm nobody before I even met you
guys and now I mean but this is the norm
like I go anywhere in the world you know
always leave knowing people and having
extended family you know we're treating
ourselves before we have dinner I have
this I have this belief that when you're
older you choose whatever you want you
choose your schedules right so I have
dessert often before I have my dinner
just as a reminder that I control what I
do what I want right nobody else I have
more freedoms now than I ever did
so let's celebrate I asked myself this
question how do you know when you should
wait on something on a relationship on a
job or how do you how do you really know
how to make a big decision on anything
with your widow with a partner for
example right business partner your gut
will always tell you before your
rational side and chest bliss that you
should make a change not enough people
listen to their guts not enough too many
people stay take in in that job that
decaying that dying job that became the
got relationship because they're worried
they give it up they're gonna lose
something it's I feel like some cost
it's like I put time in already put six
years in I would put this money in if I
let it go I'm gonna lose it but it's
already gone you never getting it back
said you should be like I have 40 years
of my life left I need to go and take
that somewhere else and and and so it's
you got it
[Music]
things like wooden spool for you worked
five years in it you know you're gonna
let all he did look at her Prentice
chick did all this equals an hour all
the sweat you know yeah I hate it now
twenty years right that's exactly his
basic God like restarted my life it's
like I'm seventeen again I just got out
of high school I like though yeah when I
turn thirty that's when I reset my life
that's like a pivotal point in that Oh
YouTube like I told myself mentally
I'm always gonna be 30
[Music]
yeah just like all
like her life yet reevaluating your life
here on my directions right I just feel
like what's right or I can take the next
30 years and be like man like the water
thought that I would need you're at 30
years old right so it's you
[Music]
instead of Mike
[Music]
yeah you felt how you show lose just
drop yeah
at 30 foot I know exactly
31 gonna be 32 this year did you steal
from your little girl they hear guys
talk about this the dummy this is a
conversation only as female
we have never had I'm the owner this is
a Toronto things marriage is cool cool
cool you guys are you know so I
appreciate like being a fly on the wall
I listen to this because this is like
really helpful for me to understand
yes I just like Oh
[Music]
so how did that day start so we met here
at 11 a.m. to go and get our tattoos
there they're covered right now I wish I
could show you guys for me this was an
emotional roller coaster I had a couple
panic attacks even after the tattoo was
done I'd be like talking for a little
bit I'm like oh my gosh what did I do
but all I know I got really emotional
and I get him I'm getting emotional not
just when I picture the word belong it's
just it brings out this this joy and
this it's weird it's also fear right I
can't explain it's not a bad kind of
fear but it's it's like there's more
more I can do better with you know what
I mean like I can grow more just insane
thank you I know I mean oh thank you
yeah I mean because if it wasn't for you
if you didn't decide to do this then I
would have I would probably honestly
been okay with it but I would have been
like you know what I you know I missed
that opportunity you know and I mean I
really need to start learning how to
hold myself accountable said of putting
all that weight on you but it was kind
of fun to put it on you not knowing you
but honestly thank you for the skill I
knew I was gonna be bringing some things
home to to to the states but I never
knew out gonna be coming back with what
a tattoo and a new found respect for
myself I mean yeah I mean I truly am so
proud of myself and I can honestly say
that you know I've always been proud of
myself but like now this is like dude I
can take pain and I can transfer this
pain to like anything in my life now so
thank you love you so much I'm honestly
not looking forward to leaving tomorrow
not that I don't want to go back to my
normal life but because I just don't
want this moment to end I really want to
stay here and get to know Alex better
and Evan better I mean I know them
through the workshop but I really I need
people like this in my life and and
trust me I'm going to manifest more
people like you in my life
and feel free to come to Dallas any time
but New Orleans no oh yeah I knew all
this New Orleans
legit on my bucket list like you don't
okay huh me huh huh when do you want to
go to New Orleans by the end of the
scale if we don't go to New Orleans by
the end of this year we got to get
another tattoo when we see each other
part two
all right done all right oh part two
yeah I know I know it's okay so we don't
learn New Orleans but in this year even
you know we gonna do all this tattoo -
okay oh yeah no no no no no I'm gonna
hold myself accountable but is there
we'll go to New Orleans or I'm getting a
touch every city you go into okay I'm
not gonna put those more stipulation I'm
sorry let's stop all right yeah so cool
you all buddy in the year party
alexander haig on yours if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like I am Tulsa what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning throw thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access